hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for Honda hunter and
Hunter hunter related accessories and
today nen is being thrown into the
forefront of discussion once more now
I've done a lot of videos explaining
nan-in abilities and even then users
however up until now they've all had
quite a positive spin on them but I
don't think that we should be ignoring
the dark underbelly of mediocrity any
longer because as much as there are
phenomenal men wielders in the series
there are also some pretty awful nen
users as well and today it is time to
name and shame them now before we get
right into it I want to clear up my
criteria for this list because honda
hunter is not a simple series and the
nen power system cannot be as easily
ranked as other Shonen systems
the thing about nan is that it is a very
personal expression and as a result
there are some uses with abilities that
are objectively worse or weaker than
other users however just because a
person's personal expression of nan
yields that kind of met ability does not
necessarily make them one of the worst
end users the criteria I would like to
judge this list on aims to level the
playing field some what I'm going to be
taking into account things like raw
potential of the user and what I mean by
that is that if someone were saying nan
prodigy who is capable of completely out
crossing most characters in the series
through natural talent alone but never
applies themselves to reach their true
potential then that in my eyes is a
horrible nan user and I want you to keep
that in mind because they are probably
going to be characters on this list who
may surprise you with their presence but
don't worry because whenever we get to
them I will be very very clear as to why
I believe they belong here not that the
internet is going to listen anyway and
I'm sure that there will be a bunch of
complaints from people incapable of
listening to what I'm saying literally
right now but I think that's half the
fun of YouTube isn't it and finally I'll
only really be exploring characters who
we have a solid understanding of in
terms of nan because there are a ton of
uses in the series where we've seen
nothing or next to nothing from and they
don't necessarily think that it's fair
to judge them on that alone but with
that out of the way let's begin welcome
to the top 5 worst end users in Hunter
hunter number 5
Basho all right so we're commencing this
list with an associate of Karaka whom we
first met in New York New City Arc as
one of jnana strods bodyguards and a
figure who was currently aboard the
black whale one serving is yet another
bodyguard in the succession war and you
know bar show is a pretty cool guy he
has a bold sense of fashion and a great
hand-to-hand combat style however this
proficiency does not quite translate
well into the world of men despite the
fact that rather incredibly Basha
probably has one of the most overpowered
abilities that this series has to offer
in case you don't remember he has a
heart to known as great haiku which
essentially involves bozo writing a
haiku on a strip of paper and then
whatever is written on it in haiku form
becomes real I'll repeat that last part
for posterity whatever is written on it
becomes real now of course this ability
does come with a heavily detrimental
condition which is that if the haiku is
bad which is a very subjective criteria
then the overall effects of the power
will be significantly weakened not a big
deal there right I mean all you have to
do is write a great oh wait he's an
awful writer oh dear you know what
though that's still not bad
in fact this ability is still pretty
damn amazing anything you've write will
become real even if it's garbage writing
and that thing only becomes real to a
lesser degree this ability still holds
infinite potential and how exactly does
basho use it well we've only seen it in
action twice and both times he's used it
to summon flames so he has this vast
universe of all creation and every
conceivable scenario at his fingertips
but I guess the dude likes fire sure and
the thing is that unlike most nin
abilities great haiku is actually really
at odds with bozo it's a power that's
difficult to build in combat unless you
have pre-prepared haikus and even then
all he likes doing is making fire but
he's also a self-confessed horrible poet
so even the one thing he does craft
comes to life in a neutered form so yeah
I don't know Basho just seems like a
very ordinary user and with the pool of
candidates in the series I would go so
far as to say one of the worst in Hunter
hunter number four revolt so most of you
will probably know him as quote that guy
from Heaven's Arena who did a thing
about time and that's how I feel like
revolt his best remembered but you know
what to give the guy some credit he did
make it all the way to the 200th floor
of heavens arena without knowing a
single thing
then after which he was brutally
initiated by an opponent who knew much
better than him and paralyzed for life
hence the wheelchair very sad story but
at least he was introduced to the world
of men right well yes but did he really
make anything out of that knowledge most
certainly not
so revelled signature hot suit is known
as a reversed which involves him
releasing a burst of aura from the back
of his wheelchair and that that's kind
of it I mean I guess I should say that
in his situation he may have been a bit
unlucky being a natural emitter and so
it would have been a bit more difficult
for him to use net as effectively as his
other two disabled friends did but at
the same time look he is almost
certainly the worst emitter we've ever
seen well he really does is use known as
a Mario cop mushroom to run away he
doesn't even use it to attack which is
generally the most amazing advantage of
a mission being able to assault people
with pure aura and you know Revo could
even use his over boast to propel
himself at enemies and hit them like a
glorified bull but instead what he does
is use our bursts to retreat to a safe
distance then assume a completely static
state and engage in some fancy whip
choreography so not only did Ravel
create an underwhelming ability but he
also never even applied that ability
properly and let's be real here the only
reason why he isn't sitting at number
one on this list is because he had very
little potential to begin with poor guy
but oh well number three gone freaks no
I am not joking I'd like to start out by
saying I really like gone I think that
he's a pretty cool show name protagonist
but as Honda hunter went on and on and
on I was consistently shocked at just
how basic his use of nannies and before
I go any further I do want to explain
myself here because I think it's very
important to keep in mind that Gunn's
natural talent for nen is nigh on
unfathomable for some comparison let's
briefly look at slush remember at all
sushi this kid was said to be 1 in
100,000 20 came to potential in regards
to nen and gone just came in and
completely eclipsed him making gone at
least one in a million if not even rarer
and not only that but rather oddly we
have also seen the full extent of God's
name potential during the Chimera ant
arc where he made a vow to briefly
attain all of the power he would ever
have and well it was a lot to say the
least everything just comes so easily to
gone it's not that he doesn't work hard
it's just that he was born to wield men
with his casual access to incredible
oral reserves this kid could create any
number of maddening hatsu or and hear me
out here or he could spend the entire
series playing scissors paper rock and
you know what he would choose to do the
latter now don't get me wrong Joe John
can attack son not as simple as they
seem and they require a very solid
mastery of basic man to even implement
effectively but in the end they all
accomplish a very simple and very
similar goal gong can essentially
perform a super punch a super cut and a
projectile shot it's not exactly all
inspiring menus and it lacks the
versatility and nuance that nan uses
with a mere fraction of gongs talent
possess and it's so obvious when Khan
does invoke his limited transformation
ability that his potential is endless he
could develop any number of amazing
powers but instead it's always summon or
a hit enemy win battle
well sometimes win battle most times
lose arm then maybe still win battle so
yeah in this case it's all about sheer
potential versus actual output and I
don't think there has been a single
instance in the series apart from the
limited transformation that gone has
even come close to his own potential and
I do want you to keep that idea in mind
as we move on to number two mara Webb
all right let the rage comments begin
um Khmer om is the strongest character
in the series how can this idiot
youtuber put him on this list
unsubscribed and disliked well look just
hear me out here I've said it before and
I'll say it roughly 1,300 times more in
this channel but marijuana is indeed the
strongest character we've encountered in
hunter hunter but to call him a great
end user would be a blatant lie in fact
call him a good nen user is even
questionable everything I said about gon
applies to marijuana times infinity I
don't think we will ever meet character
in the series with the staggering amount
of aura of marijuana coupled with the
genius-level intellect and raw power to
use it at its full potential marijuana
do that there most of his time on this
planet or was just a thing that was
there and I guess to be fair marijuana
didn't usually need to invoke it beyond
its basic applications
he was just naturally that powerful that
nobody was able to force him to push
past a fraction of the power the
he had access to in fact in his time
marijuana developed only a single Honsou
which is hora synthesis and the other
abilities he ended up with but just a
couple of cool trinkets taken from
absorbing parts of his own royal God the
thing is that marijuana existence just
kind of bypasses the entire NAND power
system he did not partake in it as it
was intended to be used and as a result
not only did Mara well never reach his
ludicrously high potential but I would
argue that he never even began the
journey to get there he is most
certainly the strongest character in the
series us far and that was to his great
detriment in the art of nen he never had
to use nen beyond a passing whim and
that's why he lands on this list today
but even with that waste of literally
limitless potential
we still have one horrible candidate
left to examine number one cheat - oh
dear oh dear what a glorious failure of
an end-user Sochi two lands kind of in
between Ghana and marijuana in terms of
natural talent as a high-ranking chimera
and cheetah was gifted with an affinity
for nen but a large majority of humanity
could only dream of however the great
tragedy of Chi 2 is that he is entirely
unable to craft nen abilities in a
thoughtful manner and as such they
always end up providing him with a
disadvantage of some sort rather than
benefiting his own personal style the
latter being what nan generally does -
almost every other user in the series so
for example as a conjurer she too was
able to create a pocket and in dimension
via Hatsune and his tag and cheetahs
intended use of this dimension was to
take advantage of his speed as the only
way that his target could leave the
dimension before the allotted time was
up was to catch Chi - however what he
neglected to understand was that
creating an ability like this does not
invoke an urgent game of catch but
rather forced his opponent to simply
wait patiently while cheetah himself is
highly irritable and energetic however
Cheechoo can't go on to force his
opponent to engage because if he gets
too close to them than they might touch
him thus deactivating tack it was a
pretty poorly thought-out power to say
the least although my personal favorite
Chi - failure is his hot - where he
conjures a crossbow the speed of which
is significantly slower than Chi -
himself thus making his projectile
attack entirely pointless especially if
an opponent is accustomed to facing Chi
to speed the projectiles would be
travelling at a snail's pace in
comparison and it's just the biggest
waste of talent that one can imagine
because whenever one of his abilities
fails
just creates another one because that's
what you can do with this stupidly
natural talent chiju is like that guy we
all knew in high school who came from a
very wealthy family and who would be
incredibly negligent about expensive
things like phones or cameras because
even if he broke them he knew that Daddy
would buy him a new one that is g2 in
regards to menus and thus even though g2
never had the potential of marijuana I
believe that he is undoubtedly the worst
nen user in the series by an order of
magnitude and that pretty much does it
for the top 5 worst nen users in Hunter
hunter if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produced in general
and please do consider donating to the
New World review patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your own worst nen users in Hunter
hunter this has been the New World
review and I'll see you next time
don't you find hunter hunt and
inabilities a little too complicated to
follow yes and no I mean there are some
abilities that are simple to a fault but
others do require you to actually sit
down and think about them for a bit
which having started hunt hunt with the
anime I will admit that it sometimes
does not give you that little bit of
extra time you may need to fully ingest
something in the manga it's much easier
because you read the explanations of
abilities at your own pace and it's
really worth it because there are some
fascinating ones out there usually the
more complex the ability the more
rewarding it is to see it in action with
that solid understanding where do you
live slash come from country so I hail
from the wonderful land of Australia a
lot of American people think I'm British
and a lot of Australian people think I'm
American but there you have it I'm often
told that I don't sound like a typical
Australian much I choose to take as a
compliment what advice would you give
your 10 year old self alright 10 year
old me listen up in a couple of months
there is going to be this new craze
called Pokemon cards you're going to get
involved heavily involved and when you
open that booster pack with that base
set Charizard the first thing you're
going to do is put it into a sleeve and
seal it away for decades on end that way
when you get older and become future
Liam which to me is present Liam you can
then sell that card for thousands of
dollars but whatever you do do not trade
it away for Pokemon that you like better
please do not make my mistakes